رغم افراج السلطات كوسوفو عن الشرطي
المنتمي للاقليه الصربيه الذي تسبب
اعتقاله في العاشر من ديسمبر الجاري
بتفاقم بحاله التوتر الشماليه البلاد
وصولا الى ازمه مفتوحه مع صربيا فان تصاعد
المخاوف من تفجر الاوضاع هناك لا يزال
حاضرا في ظل اغلاق المحتاجين صرب لاكبر
معبر حدود مع جارتهم الجنوبيه واستمرار
اغلاق طرقات الرئيسيه بالقوه من قبل
الاقليه الصربيه الشماليه كوسوفو تبدو
حكومه برستينا مصممه على المضيء بعيدا في
مساعها لفرض السياده على كل اراضيها في
الوقت الذي منحته لقوات حفظ السلام لكي
تتحرك ينفذ بسرعه وهي تعلن انها لن
تتسامحها مع من وضع الحواجز على الطرق
وستواصل النشره المزيد من وحدات الشرطه
شماليه البلاد ولن تتحدث او تتعاون مع من
وصفتهم بالمجرمين بل ستعتقلهم
موقف ياتي بعد قرار الرئيس الصربي وضع
الجيش في حاله تاهب القصوى وزياره وزير
الدفاع الصربي الى قاعده عسكريه قريبه من
الحدود مع كوسوفو وعلى ما يبدو فان تردد
العلاقات بين الغرب وروسيا بسبب الحرب على
اوكرانيا يلقي بظلاله على المشهد غربي
البلقان اذ سبق لوزير الداخليه الكوسوفي
ان اتهم الصربيا بالسعي لزعزعه استقرار
بلاده بتوجيه من روسيا لكنه موسكو صارعت
بمثل الاتهامات بتاجيج التوتر وان اكد
الناطق باسم الكرم دعم بلاده بلاد في
ازماتها الراهنه مع بريشتينا في حين اعربت
الخارجيه الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي عن
قلقهما ازاء استمرار التوتر في شمال كسوفو
وذكر بيان مشترك ان الجانبين يعملان مع
جميع الاطراف لايجاد حل سياسيازع التوتر
والاتفاق على خريطه طريق صالح الاستقرار
في تقع منذ انفصلت كوسوفو عن صربيا عام
1999 وحتى بعد ان اعلنت استقلالها عام
2008 ما زالت صربيا تعدها جزءا من ارضها
وتدعم الاقليه الصربيه فيها ففي الاجزاء
الشماليه من كوسوفو يعيش نحو 50 الف صربي
ويرفضون الاعتراف بها دوله مستقله او
بحكومتها وينظرون الى بلغراد على انها
عاصمه لهم تصاعد التوتر بين الجارتين منذ
ان حاولت حكومه برستينا الزام الصربي في
اجزائها الشماليه باستبدال لوحات السيارات
التي يعود تاريخها الى ما قبل حرب كوسوفو
باخرى من اصدار المحلي ما تسبب باستقالات
جماعيه للصربي من الشرطه ثم ازداد الوضع
احتقانا بعد اعتقال شرطين سابق من صربيك
وسوفو ليرد الصرب باقامه حواجز على الطرق
ورفض الجنسيه على مطالب حكومه كوسوفو
بازاالتها